We are asked to fit a thread of one meter
in this small box.
It will be easy if we simply coil the thread
and place it inside.
Did you know that a similar approach is taken
by our cells?
Let’s see how!
We know that the long stretch of DNA
is coiled to a great extent to fit inside the tiny nucleus.
This process of coiling gives rise to the
chromatid structure.
It is a thread like mesh that we find in the nucleus
of a metabolically active cell.
The chromatids gain a typical classical structure
which looks somewhat like this!
It is seen during cell division!
And these are nothing but the chromosomes!
But tell me, do all chromosomes look exactly like this?
Do all the 46 chromosomes look the same?
If yes, then why do we say that there are 23 pairs
of chromosomes?
What helps us categorise these chromosomes as pairs?
Well, all chromosomes are not exactly like one another.
They come in types, depending upon their structures
or shapes and functions!
The first basis for classification is shapes!
We know this is the structure of a typical chromosome.
And is this a single chromosome?
That's right!
The difference is that this
chromosome is not duplicated.
While this one has a duplicated copy attached to itself!
So these are the duplicated sister chromatids
which are attached to the same chromosome.
Now to understand the types, let us first understand
the typical structure.
Here, these two regions are called
the arms of the chromosome.
This arm is named as the “P” arm.
And this is known as the “Q” arm.
So how do we recognise which is the “P”
and which is the “Q” arm?
Is it based on their positions?
Nope!
It depends on the size!
The smaller arm is the “P” arm
while the larger one is the “Q” arm.
So this chromosome has one “P” and one “Q” arm.
While this one has two “P” and two “Q” arms.
Now let us focus on this chromosome structure.
Can you guess what this structure is called
to which the arms are attached?
Well,
this knot like structure is called “Centromere”.
It is the portion of DNA that acts as a link
between the two sister chromatids.
But that is not its sole purpose!
Its major function is the attachment of spindle fibres
during the cell division process!
And let me
tell you one more interesting use of the centromere.
It is the position of the centromere that helps us
categorise the chromosomes into four types.
The four types include Metacentric, Sub-metacentric,
Acrocentric
and Telocentric chromosomes.
Let us have a look at the structures of each type!
Aren’t these simple to understand?
This one is called Metacentric type.
As we can see, the centromere is placed
almost exactly at the centre.
The two arms seem almost of the same length.
We can say that the centromere is placed somewhat
in the middle of the complete structure.
Now the next type is the Submetacentric.
Here, the centromere is placed slightly
away from the centre.
As a result, the two arms of the chromosome
appear unequal.
The next type is the Acrocentric.
In this, the centromere is seen
almost towards the end region.
The term “acro” in Greek relates to “peak”.
Thus the name “acrocentric” refers to the type
where the centromere is near the terminal region.
Lastly, what we see is that the centromere
is present at the extreme end.
That is,
the centromere is placed at the telomeric region.
Hence the name, telocentric!
However,
these chromosomes are not found in humans!
The human karyotype lacks telocentric chromosomes!
But what is karyotype, you may ask!
Well,
it is one way of representing all the chromosomes
found in a cell.
This is how chromosomes are classified
on the basis of their structures or shapes to be precise.
Now let us have a look at the
other type of classification.
This is a much simpler type of classification.
Here,
the chromosomes are classified whether they are
Autosomes or sex chromosomes.
Now what could these be?
This is a representative image
of a typical human karyotype!
The chromosomes that pair from one to twenty two,
are called autosomes.
That is, they are not the sex chromosomes.
To be precise, they have got
no function to deal with the sex of the individual.
The last pair however, determines the sex of the person.
So if the two are identical,
that is both are “X” and “X”,
then the individual is a female.
And what if both are different?
In such a case, when one chromosome is “X”
and the other is “Y”,
the individual is a male.
This pair is the sex chromosomes.
So the chromosomes which help in determining
the sex of an individual
are sex chromosomes
or even called allosomes.
The others which are from first to 22nd pair,
are NOT the sex chromosomes.
This makes them the autosomes.
Both contain genes that code for proteins
which make up our body!
Now that we have understood the various
types of chromosomes,
can you tell me
what helps in determining the sex of an individual?
Is it only the chromosomes?
Or is it some other factor too?
Tune into the next part
to understand the interesting concept of
Sex Determination in various organisms!